avengers infinity war proved that it
takes quite a lot to make thanos cry
usually marvel's massive purple titan is
as strong on the inside as he appears on
the outside
especially when it comes to causing
serious mayhem after all he was already
proudly decimating half the existing
population in the universe one planet at
a time
before acquiring the infinity stones and
powering up the infinity gauntlet which
offered him greater efficiency in
achieving his goal
a simple snap of his fingers at the end
of avengers infinity war in the universe
was only half as full of living things
as it was the moment before
and thanos couldn't have been happier
about it he even sacrificed one of his
adoptive daughters gamora to get his
hands on the soul stone
which requires the seeker to offer up
the thing they love most in the world as
a sacrifice before acquiring it
though thanos is undeniably a genocidal
maniac with skewed morals the human who
brought him to life on the big screen is
thankfully the complete opposite
sure he's muscular and strong with a
booming voice but thanos actor josh
brolin is quite soft at heart
in fact brolin previously confessed that
he had complicated feelings about a
scene in which thanos kills one of his
many victims
feeling bad for both the character and
the actor on the receiving end of thanos
ruthlessness
and no despite the fact that killing
gamora made his character thanos cry
that's not the one he was talking about
what did it cost
[Music]
everything in a july 2018 interview with
usa today
brolin identified the avengers infinity
war scene in which thanos brutally kills
loki played by tom hiddleston as a scene
he didn't totally enjoy filming
the moment happens very early on in the
movie when thanos and his pack a black
order henchmen intercept the grandmaster
spaceship that's carrying loki
thor heimdall the hulk and the other
asgardians who became refugees after
surter destroyed asgard at the end of
thor ragnarok
loki offers to be thanos and company's
guide when they eventually touch down on
earth but he's actually deceiving him
hoping to get close enough to thanos so
he can stab and kill him
this backfires and thanos uses the space
stone inside the infinity gauntlet to
freeze loki's arm in mid-air
with one hand thanos smacks loki's knife
to the ground and with the other
chokes and kills him roland knew this is
what had to be done for the story but
that doesn't mean he was all smiles and
laughter throughout filming to this
particular scene
the actor felt especially bad for tom
hiddleston who had at that point been
playing loki in the mcu for the better
part of a decade
roland told usa today he had been with
that character for so long and he was so
lauded for doing it
so choking him out wasn't the most fun
thing i had ever done
while brolin didn't have any fun and
effectively taking away one of
hiddleston's most popular roles he did
find pleasure in the backlash it caused
the actor added that on instagram people
are saying things like i hate you
that's fantastic i'm like the one guy
who smiles when he sees that
it's like it worked brolin later
revealed in the same interview that he
also took pleasure in a different aspect
of the very same scene
thanos beating the hulk in a one-on-one
fist fight which he found rather
satisfying
roland said i love that thanos uses a
knee that was great
the good news after the fact is that
avengers infinity war isn't the last
fans get to see of loki
the god of mischief albeit a version of
the character who didn't die and instead
escaped with the space stone during the
avengers time heist and end game will
star in his very own series on disney
plus set to premiere on july 11
2021 hopefully this happy ending makes
brolin feel a little bit better about
the last scene he shared with hiddleston
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic book movie moments
are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one